Speaker 1: Let's continue hearing from
folks in the audience. I want to go next
to Roy Lynn from Grand Rapids, Roiland.
Welcome. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, nice talking to you again.
Last time I talked about a lot of monetary theory,
but this I'll keep it with the voting,
since that's everybody's mind. Beautiful.
First of all, thanks for repress my name
correctly. It's really rare that that happens.
Speaker 1: I don't know how else. How else
could it be pronounced? That seems so.
Speaker 2: Obvious. Roland, Ray Lynn.
I'll even know that if people don't look
like they can suppress the first time. I just
say Roy. Just say Roy. Beautiful. Okay, fine.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm glad to have you here.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So quick question. So I'll try
to get people to vote, but obviously the ballots
are all over the place, are confusing candidates.
Do you have any references or websites that
you refer to for or just progressively endorse
candidates or places that are like, you know, kind
of some kind of list of candidates that you that
people would endorse for the Progressive Caucus
or anything. I probably should have asked this
during the primaries and not the midterms. But no.
Speaker 1: I don't have any. I thought you were
going to ask a place where you can figure out
exactly where you vote based on your address
and can you vote early and can you vote absentee
and all of these different things. I'm not aware
of any central place for like an endorsement
type thing because the endorsements are made,
organizations make it. There's no
official progressive endorsements.
There's different organizations which
claim to be the clearinghouse for who
should be who should be voted for.
But no, I don't I don't know that
such a central thing really exists.
Speaker 2: That's so unfortunate
because I have people that are like ready to
vote. But when they get to the things like,
like I'm in Michigan and when you get past the
parts that say like what the Democrats are,
they don't really know who to vote for. So, yeah.
Speaker 1: So listen, what I would recommend is
if you just search on Google for Michigan
ballot 2022, the first result is a michigan
secretary of State website where you put in
exactly where you vote, you put in your county,
you put it in the jurisdiction. So it seems some
counties like, for example, you know, Bay County,
you put in exactly where you are. You even put
in your precinct and then it will show you your
exact ballot, your exact ballot with everything
that's on it as a starting point, familiarize
yourself with what you will be voting for. And
then like, for example, you know, in Michigan,
whatever, whatever I'm looking here, there is a
proposal to make some changes to how elections
are financed. You can look at that in advance
and and research what it is you believe about
that. So these aren't secrets. You know, you
don't have to wait until Election Day and then
get all confused about the things you're voting
on. Just Google at Google where you live and you
can find the exact ballot you will have.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. I was kind of more
asking for like the lazy person, you
know, because I'm aware of all this,
but I just would love to in reference to people.
Speaker 1: I mean, sadly, the lazy thing is to
just you vote. All four Democrats are all
Republicans in the races that are partizan,
which aren't all of them necessarily.
There's like non partizan media races,
but there are shortcuts. If people are looking
for them, I don't know that I recommend them.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I was. Like I said, this probably
should've been a question for during the primaries
and not this far into the election, obviously,
and since then. But also, one more thing. I had
had a chance to call since you since you had
your child. Congratulations on that. Thank you.
I do remember an episode where you kind of had
to address a grief that some of the viewers
have given you about taking time off to spend
time with your children. Yeah, your child. And
I think that's just so disappointing as a
viewer, as a listener, that you had to make
those comments because you're supposed to be like,
you know, a beacon for progressive thoughts and,
you know, had paternity leave, maternity leave
in general, something we should all aspire to
be. So the fact that you get the ability to do
that is, you know, I a lot of people probably
envy that. And I think that on your next child,
if you were to take a whole month off there,
there's plenty of us that would be totally
understanding and happy for you nonetheless.
Speaker 1: Well, I very much appreciate
that, Royal, and thank you for making
that declaration. I like it.
Speaker 2: Yes. All right. Well,
you have a good rest today, okay?
Speaker 1: You, too. There is
Roy Lynn with very important questions from
Grand Rapids, Michigan. Yes. Understand the
ballot that you will be presented with.
Just Google it. You can find it easily